fifth harmony singer normani Corday  reacts to the attack in Manchester  following an ariana grande concert it's  very scary because it's super  unpredictable people go to concerts to  have a good time and music does bring  people together it's really unfortunate  and inside I'm praying for all those  that were lost and their families nor  money spoke to ET after performing this  heartfelt and poignant routine on  Mondays finale of Dancing with the Stars  Oh  honestly it was such a moment for me and  just for me finding myself and really  finding my light and recognizing that it  didn't just take me it took the people  around me to really kind of pull that  out of me  for me to be courageous enough to let  people know who our money really is and  I want to share that with other people  and hopefully bless and inspire them